[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning the
race for president appears to be neck
and neck in what is now a very crucial
battleground state in the south
in 2016 president trump won georgia by
five points
but a new cbs news battleground tracker
poll shows joe biden tied with mr trump
and georgia now
with 49 percent each mark straussen
spoke with voters there he joins us now
from marietta that's outside atlanta
mark spouseman always good to see you
good morning
good morning to you gail good morning to
you there's suburban atlanta voters
behind me have about a half hour wait
this morning they represent
georgia's shifting demographics and
preferences a chunk of this county was
once represented by republican and
former house speaker newt gingrich
and yet four years ago hillary clinton
carried this county
and that explains why this dead even
2020 presidential race
is such a dog fight nearly 3 million
georgians have already voted early
despite lines as long as 10 hours
malcolm williams and jillian solomon
just met this 65 year old
ex-cop is a volunteer driver taking her
to vote in an organized
roll to the polls people want to vote
and for people who can't get to the
polls
it can be incredibly frustrating naca a
neighborhood assistance non-profit
has 100 vans on georgia's roads so far
drivers like williams have taken 12
thousand people to vote
i'm not even interested in who they
voted for you don't ask republican
democrat independent
you know snow white i don't care it
doesn't matter to me we're going to fill
out some forms here
george is changing with one million more
registered voters than in 2016.
it's younger more diverse than ever no
longer reliably read
the president and his family have
repeatedly campaigned in a state
republicans once saw as an automatic win
his handling of covid and the covet
economy divides voters here
where the cdc is headquartered
another wedge issue back in june
protesters took to atlanta streets
as part of the black lives matter
demonstration the president's call for
law and order divides georgians by race
according to our cbs battleground
tracker
65 percent of white georgia voters say
it makes them feel protected
but 71 percent of black georgia voters
believe
it makes their lives more dangerous
racial justice
is jillian solomon's core issue she
voted for biden
we're to heal that's why we have to come
together
we spotted chris stevens on georgia's
first day of early voting
this registered democrat a hillary
clinton supporter four years ago
waited more than three hours to vote in
savannah but biden lost his vote to
trump
over one issue if you win this election
you're going to pack that court
i think that's a radical thing biden has
avoided answering whether he'd pack the
court
and said he'd appoint a commission to
study the issue but
if there's one dominant issue here it's
kovit
georgia was one of the last states to
close its economy because of the virus
and one of the first to reopen malcolm
williams gives every passenger a
temperature check
a final reminder of kovit's impact
before heading to the polls
it's the most important election of my
lifetime do you think a lot of these
folks
you're driving it means the same to them
because people are hurting
people are afraid we hope by voting that
it will make a difference
former vice president biden will
campaign in atlanta tomorrow
and remember what our cbs battleground
tracker showed a race tied dead even at
49 a piece
anthony that also means there are very
few undecided voters left here yeah
i think it's great what malcolm is doing
driving people the polls and i'd be
curious how those polls show snow white
is doing it
please mentioned her please remind
people anthony
do not vote for stonewall she's got no
chance
all right mark thanks so much